yeah well i think both players actually
showing that they want to have some fun
and they want some blood in this game
because i mean magnus also after e4
playing the provocative g6 so no e4 e5
no sicilians whatsoever just going for
the piers defense or modern defense as
as people want to to call it because
he's he has not committed the knight
from g8 to f6 so quickly
so d4d6 knight 60 bishop g7 bishop is
the a6
and this is one of the points yeah that
when white plays the setup with bishop
e3 and queen d2 if black develops the
knight to f6 there might be a very quick
bishop h6 coming
but
by delaying the knight movement from
from g8 it makes basically not so much
sense for white immediately rush for
these ideas i mean okay you you play the
move but you're not going to get bishop
h6
b5 fc knight d7 h4 yeah you make some
provocation please show me do you play
h5 then i get chance to get my knight to
g5 for example via h3 if you're gonna
play the move h6 then you will have
trouble with your h6 pawn yeah and
magnus plays uh knight gf6 which makes
perfect sense he still delays any
decision with his h-pawn arjun went long
castle and we are in for a very big
battle you want to play too good yeah
it's very dangerous and magnus did play
the movie h5 yeah making sure that there
won't be any bishop h6 because yeah this
this thread of the dark bishops could be
very unpleasant he definitely does not
want to castle what he wants to go do is
to to develop bishop b7 get maybe pawn
to e6 knight b6 queen e7 and then maybe
long castle himself
uh but navi got a chance now let me show
you this line e4 e5 because uh of course
if black takes d5 d5 knight takes e5
runs into queen takes d8 checkmate
that's the kind of the whole point of
white setup but now we get to this
position that we have been talking about
e5 met by b4 and it's on the board yeah
e takes f6 mad by btx c3
and knight a4 you can come with a knight
to d5 so you get a nice spot for your
own knight if white moves the night away
then you can simply place your knight in
the center of the board hit that bishop
on e3
yeah actually it will be interesting
talk about it afterwards uh but yeah for
the look at this by the way arjun has
played knight v195 bishop g5 and i was
saying magnus might not be too happy
just two moves ago i think now he's very
happy i mean okay this uh this knight b1
does not scare anyone i mean it's
definitely not the the right direction
but i would like to highlight before we
move on to something that why i think
that arjun did not like the move knight
a4 so knight a4 knight d5 e6
f6 bishop dc which is very thematic
black plays the seemingly passive move
knight f8 protecting the weakness on g6
and suddenly has a threat of [ __ ] going
bishop d7 targeting the knight on a4 and
and suddenly this knight on a4 will find
itself in a very awkward position
so this this was something that he did
not like but in this regard then i feel
like he might have just missed e5 before
because you don't you you you don't
decide uh before going e5 to to play
knight b1 then it would have been just
much better continue the plan go knight
hd knight g5 king b1 and let's just play
chess i mean right position is kind of
nice yeah there was no need to to start
this action if in fact the action
doesn't uh work out invites favor
look at that knight and the queen 94
made to play to try and create a lift
for the king on d2 after queen takes b2
he wants to try to run but it looks like
you're not going to be running too far
wow i mean not only that
white king is basically the mating
attack but also look at i mean i have
never seen a bishop trapped on g6 like
this i mean that's supposed to be a
black pawn there not a white bishop on
g6
definitely i mean this whole
construction yeah that there are like
almost four bishops next to each other
yeah the bishop on e6 a little bit
spoils the the picture but i mean
just incredible also the black phone on
f7 targeting the g6 bishop the pawn from
f5 targeting the e6 but it does not
matter anything because actually magnus
is just breaking slow on the queen queen
side and checkmating white's king in the
center
he's going for the king he's going for
the king so knight c3 played it hits the
queen queen d3 you can now pick up the
knight on e4 knight e4 and then plant
the other knight on c3 the only thing
you need to watch out for is queen b5
check which might allow some counter
play but as long as you have the b5
square under control black is dominating
yeah for sure i mean also if you just
can't mate i think black is already
pulling up and uh yeah white king is in
a lot of trouble on the other hand we we
do see that the computer means that
there should be or there could be a
potential knockout blow
can you just simply
step back with your bishop yeah i was
just gonna point out this move peter
what you're saying right now bishop d7
hitting that bishop on g6 and first i
thought wait a second what about the f7
pawn but then as you were just
mentioning that bishop b5 i don't see a
square for white's queen
exactly yeah that's that's the spirit of
the of the play yeah because
it just ends yeah the queen on dc is
trapped i mean we don't really see too
often and it's on the board it's played
by magnus
and it's funny we were talking about how
black needs to be careful about not
allowing white's queen to get to b5 but
instead magnus finds this idea of
getting his own bishop on b5 and
trapping white's queen this could just
be a resignation
by
arjun now i don't see a way how he can
keep up
dealing with this pressure and this
threat
yeah i think it just resigns i mean
there is just nothing to be done
i mean magnus just has destroyed arjun
and and here we see that uh how big
psychologist magnus is yeah that he
somehow sensed correctly that uh it's
the first game i should just uh get
arjun out of his comfort zone yet don't
play anything that he might expect and
we have seen uh lately actually magnus
was throwing a lot with uh
with playing the the piers
uh but still i don't think that arjun
could have expected because pierce
always comes as a surprise yeah like it
almost feels like your opponent
underestimates you yeah that he's ready
to willing to take the risk of uh going
for something yeah now white has
sacrificed the queen the only problem is
that he doesn't get enough and in fact
not only does not get enough yeah he
needs to design and he designed all
right and that's it magnus wins the
first game